all right this is how I think it really
went down I don't even think Joseph
gordon-levitt is in the movie looper I
think someone went back in time and got
young Bruce Willis brought him to the
present and put him in a movie that is
what happened looper so the movie looper
takes place in the Year 2044 time-travel
has not been invented yet but it
eventually will be and it becomes
immediately illegal the only ones who
really use it are like organized crime
people and mobsters who want to kill
people and they can't dispose of though
they can't kill people in their time
everything's tracked you just can't
dispose of a body you will get caught
what they can do is take someone send
him back to the Year 2044 where a looper
will be waiting for him that's what
Joseph gordon-levitt does he stands
there with his blunderbuss scattergun
the person appears blows him away
disposes of the body so past the Year
2044 the person just disappears off the
map but in the Year 2044 the looper
disposes of the body the body of a
person who probably doesn't even exist
yet a fail-safe system if you ask me but
then one day Joseph gordon-levitt's
waiting for the person to appear that
he's gonna blow away and his Bruce
Willis yes it's older him from the
future blows his mind and then Bruce
Willis gets the drop on him and now it's
kind of a manhunt so that's what the
trailer tells you in reality there's a
lot more going on in the movie looper
than just that and I love seeing that it
could have been just a simple premise
you know Joseph gordon-levitt needs to
kill Bruce Willis and Bruce Willis is
trying to get away but this movie had
layers friends and they were good layers
first of all one of the things that
impressed me is when Joseph
gordon-levitt's doing his voiceover he's
talking about the world they live in
what he does is a looper you feel like
this person who's done this job for a
few years is telling you how it works
you know and a premise is thought out
like that and explained to you well
you're like all right yeah the world now
has relevance you know it has clout
another thing I loved about this movies
Bruce Willis's story is ultimately
Joseph gordon-levitt's life story also
it's not like the two were completely
different characters Bruce Willis is
what Joseph gordon-levitt will become in
that they both have to be relevant
characters and you have to know where
both of them are coming from it does a
good job at not making it Joseph
gordon-levitt who has to kill Bruce
Willis well rather it's one dilemma of
one person's life converged and met at
this point that was really cool it being
a time travel movie that makes this
movie tricky because there are things
that will happen in the past they have
to do with the future and cause and
effect where you can't help but look at
it and go I don't know if time really
works that way but they do a good job at
illustrating in this movie that this is
how time works in this movie
explain it to you yet keep it vague in
the like look we're not even going to
talk about this that's the way I've been
like look no one really knows to cause
an effective time travel no one really
knows how it would work and if you say
you do newsflash you don't really know
the things that are going on in this
movie I don't even want to tell you
about you just have to fund it the movie
is seeing it you're like oh I didn't
expect a movie to be like this I didn't
expect it to go here now gonna rob you
that I'm not gonna spoil the movie
but just know it's in there all the
actors did a great job with their
characters in this movie Jeff Daniels is
in this movie he's Joseph
gordon-levitt's boss he's one of those
characters it's not in the movie much
but he's a relevant character and the
lines that he had were good that kind of
feeds into my point of view in the
dialogue in this movie is the dialogue
is really good in this movie it was
written really well because the people
in this movie don't just talk shop they
don't just talk business there's small
talk there's bickering there's bent or
back-and-forth that's what Quentin
Tarantino scripts and Joss Whedon
scripts are great because they do that
really well this movie has elements of
that it makes the dialogue feel real
between the characters there is this
little kid in the movie and little kids
in sci-fi movies can be the kiss of
death you just like I hope this works
out this little kid actor is a really
good actor you're gonna see this kid
more I don't always say that about
kids in movies usually they're the
complete weak link for this kid he was a
legit I liked them in the end you
already knew the premise of looper was
interesting because the trailer showed
you that you're like yeah that's
interesting enough I want to check it
out but the movie had great actors
playing solid characters with great
dialog some cool action in the movie but
it wasn't overly sci-fi cheese it was
interesting it was intriguing it had
heart it had relevance it basically
surprised me on every level because it's
a sci-fi movie coming out in September
we've been here before they're never as
good as you want them to be however
looper the sci-fi movie that came out in
September about time travel is awesome
tacular
there is an element in this movie where
I was like this is so Terminator 1 but
the movie as a whole is so unique
original and compelling that even though
this one element is familiar the movie
still makes it its own so you end up
being like alright that's cool so your
favorite story that has to do with
time-travel what is it a lot of people
are gonna say back to the future but
really dig deep if it's Back to the
Future them say back to the future well
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more